було дуже багато заяв цими днями від
уряду від пана шмигаля коли він
буквально 29 грудня Минулого року вони
прийняли е черговий документ на кабінеті
міністрів Він сказав що після прийняття
оцієї нової системи оплати держ
держслужбовцям бюджет зекономить 8 млрд
я не то що була здивована а просто от
чергова брехня вона вже просто шкодить
шкодить всім нам не тільки тим людям які
знають цифри і факти а всьому
суспільству тому що насправді в бюджеті
закладено навіть вперше з'явилася окрема
програма в видатках Міністерства
фінансів воно називається забезпечення
інституційної спроможності органів
державної влади і там виділяється 2,2
млрд грн на те щоби забезпечити оце
вирівнювання заробітних плат плюс 2,2 а
не міну8 млрд як говорить пан шмигаль